c'est l'un des plus gros scandales
d'État de la 5e République voici
l'affaire du Rainbow Warrior l'affaire
Greenpace est un véritable feuilleton
Politi policier une bombe a fait sauter
le chalutier de Greenpeace c'est un
mensonge organisé assumé au plus haut de
l'État ce sont des agents de la DGSE qui
ont coulé ce bâton service secret moi je
trouve qui devrait encore être plus
secret
[Musique]
parfois salut c'est cette semaine
j'avais envie de vous parler d'une
histoire incroyable celle du Rainbow
Warrior parce que cette affaire illustre
parfaitement la raison d'État
c'est-à-dire comment un état agit dans
l'ombre et l'illégalité pour préserver
ses propres intérêts et pour en parler
qui de mieux kedwi Plenel directeur de
mediap qui à l'époque a largement
contribué à révéler au grand jour ce
scandale d'État nous sommes dans la nuit
du 10 juillet 1985 au port d'Auckland en
Nouvelle-Zélande alors que l'équipage du
Rainbow war le navire amiral de
Greenpeace fête l'anniversaire d'un de
ses membres une explosion retentie à
bord les gens sortent du bateau sauf un
Fernando Pereira qui est photographe qui
accompagne Greenpeace il va dans sa
cabine pour récupérer ses appareils une
deuxème explosion plus grosse que la
première achève le Rainbow Warrior qui
coule dans le port
d'auland first mate to tell us that the
warrior hadk and that Fernando was
missing Fernando Pereira va mourir
noyé dans le journal où je travaillais à
l'époque le journal Le Monde ça ne fait
qu'une brève comme un fait d'hiver c'est
un fait divhiver et il faudra attendre
pour que ça fasse vraiment événement
début août 1985 donc pratiquement 3
semaines après pour que deux autres
journaux affirment qu'en fait derrière
ce sabotage il y a les services secrets
français 3 2 1 depuis le milieu des
années 60 la France mène des essais
nucléaires en Polynésie en 1968
elle teste une bombe H du nom de Canopus
135 fois plus puissante que la bombe
d'Hiroshima c'est l'essai atomique le
plus puissant jamais réalisé par la
France après cette réussite le général
de Gaul a déclaré c'est un magnifique
succès pour l'indépendance et la
sécurité de la France l'industrie
nucléaire accélère le développement
économique de la Polynésie française
mais une partie de la pop ultion locale
dénonce les graves conséquences sur
l'environnement sérieusement je demande
à Monsieur mitéran de prendre sa bande
et de l'envoyer en France c'est sous la
présidence de François mitteran qu'il y
aura le plus grand nombre d'écès
nucléaires organisé dans le Pacifique
c'est dans ce contexte qu'en mars 1985
le Rainbow Warrior de Greenpace gagne le
port d'land afin de mener une opération
pour empêcher les essais nucléaires
français dans l'atol de morurois
Greenpeace une organisation
internationale qui multiplie les actions
spectaculaires contre toutes les sortes
de pollutions de l'environnement naturel
depuis plusieurs mois les services
secrets français ont infiltré Greenpeace
par l'intermédiaire de la militante
Frédérique Bonlieu qui est en réalité
l'agent Christine Cabon Greenpeace a a
été totalement infiltré à cette époque
sa section française a été si infiltrée
qu'après l'attentat elle n'y survivra
pas pendant un moment il n'y aura plus
de P en France quelques jours seulement
après le naufrage du Rainbow Warrior la
police néozélandaise interpelle Sophie
et Alain turange un couple de touristes
qu'ils accusent d'appartenir au service
secret français derrière le nom d'alin
turange se cache en réalité le colonel
Alain mafar le nageur de combat
commandant des troupes de marine
derrière Sophie turange le capitaine
Dominique prieur grande blonde cheveux
longs elles seront méconnaissabl avant
de partir pour Auckland cheveux teint en
brun coupé court grosses lunett elle se
déclare jeune marié et Suisse c'est ce
dernier détail qu'il a trahi lors de son
arrestation après l' tenta du Rainbow
Warrior sur son faux passeport elle fait
inscrire son nom de jeune fille Sophie
claire Paillot ce que les suisses font
très rarement il y a une autre équipe
qui est celle du voilier ouvert ils
partent de Nouvelle-Calédonie et ils
apportent dans le voilier les tenues de
plongé et l'explosif le couple turange a
pour mission de de superviser les hommes
qui passeront à l'action cela ne fait
pratiquement plus de doute l'attentat
contre le Rainbow Warrior a été
commandité et organisé à Paris alors que
l' se resserre autour des services
secrets français le ministre de la
défense charlesn ni en bloc aucune
organisation dépendant de mon
ministère n'a reçu l'ordre de
commettre un attentat contre le war ni
il faut trouver la carte qui va faire
tomber le château de carte et c'est là
que je vais me retrouver revenant de
vacances à devoir enquêter sur cette
mystérieuse affaire alors que le premier
ministre néozélandais David Lench se
fait de plus en plus insistant dans ses
accusations à l'égard de la France le
président François mitteran lui fait
parvenir une lettre dont voici un
extrait quand je me remémore cette
histoire il y a je dirais l'inconscience
de la jeunesse je me mets sur le dossier
et commence un travail qui ne sera pas
un travail solitaire qui sera un travail
d'équipe je serai celui qui sera un peu
le fil conducteur de toute cette enquête
la police néozélandaise est dans
l'impasse car ni les épouturanges ni
l'équipe de l'ouva n'ont pu commettre
l'attentat contre le Rainbow Warrior de
son côté la France continue de nier
toute implication la
DGS n'avait pas alors en nouvelle
Zélande outre le commandant mafar et le
capitaine prieur d'autres agents que
ceux qui composaient l'équipage de
l'ouva plusieurs rumeurs sont répandu
dans la presse pour brouiller les pistes
je me fais enfumer Parah les mensonges
de l'appareil d'État il y a deux fausses
pistes qu'il commence à répandre l'une
c'est que c'est une histoire totalement
abracadabrante il y a une grande crise
en Nouvelle-Calédonie à l'époque autour
de l'indépendance il y a des extrémistes
qui combattent cette indépendance et
donc ces extrémistes de droite plutôt
auraiit monté cela pour nuire à la
présidence socialiste l'autre fausse
piste c'est l'idée d'un sabotage dans le
sabotage rien n'indique pour l'instant
que ces deux Français soient impliqués
dans l'attentat celui-ci pourrait en
effet très bien avoir été commis par une
autre équipe mêlant anciens agents de
renseignement mercenaire activist iste
d'extrême droite cherchant à nuire à
l'image de la France dans le Pacifique
au bout d'un moment on comprend quelle
est la pièce manquante et c'est comme ça
que nous allons avec un collègue du
monde Bertrand leugand et un collègue
qui travaillait au Canard enchaîné à ce
moment-là George Marion et bien tombé
sur la troisème équipe de nageurs de
combat c'est eux qui poseront les deux
bombes les deux explosifs dans la nuit
sur la coque du Rainbow
Warrior
é un haut fonctionnaire du ministère de
l'Intérieur qui m'a permis de compléter
le PZ il ne parlait pas si facilement et
et il fallait aussi accepter de boire
quelques whisky pour y arriver vous
allez
[Musique]
démissionner
écoutez votre question est tellement
drôle oui c'est ça écoutez non j'ai j'ai
pas songé et j'ai pas écrit même des
brouillons de 3 jours après les
révélations du monde sur l'existence
d'une 3ème équipe Charles Hernu
démissionne l'Admiral pierre lacost
patron de la DGSE et limogé le Premier
Ministre Laurent fabus reconnaît enfin
la responsabilité des service secret ce
sont des agents de la DGSE qui ont coulé
ce bâton ils ont agi sur
le fusible Hernu a fondu mais est-ce
suffisant pour désamorcer complètement
l'affaire sans doute une question
essentielle reste ce soir sans réponse
qui a donné l'ordre de couler le bateau
cet acte contre le navire de Greenpeace
ne pouvait avoir été fait qu'avec un
ordre et nous soulevions deux
responsabilités celle de l'état-major le
chef d'état-major des armées et le chef
d'état-major particulier du président de
la République et celle du ministre de la
Défense char Hernu qui soit avait menti
soit avait accepté qu'on lui mente
l'entêement du mensonge sera très très
fort et c'est un mensonge organisé
assumé au plus haut de l'État en 2005
l'amiral Lacoste affirmera avoir mis au
courant François mitteran en personne
j'ai tenu personnellement à vérifier
auprès de lui que ce n'était pas
seulement une initiative de son ministre
de la Défense et que Charles Hernu lui
en avait bien parlé et il m'a confirmé
qu'il était bien au courant auamo
François mitteran savait avant et n'a
pas empêché au pire François mitéran a
ordonné lui-même en Nouvelle-Zélande les
deux faux épou turange seront condamné à
10 ans de prison avant d'être expulsé un
an plus tard la France versera plusieurs
millions de francs de dommages et
intérêts à la Nouvelle-Zélande à
Greenpace et à la famille de Fernando
Pereira le photographe mort dans le
naufrage elle présentera également des
excuses officielles au gouvernement
néozélandais quant au colonel Jean-Luc
kister l'un des nageurs de combat qui a
posé les bombes il fera ses excuses à
visage découvert 30 ans après les fait
au micro d'Edou Plenel les patients se
sont apaisés et dans mon esprit aussi
mais ma conscience me dictait quand même
de de faire ses excuses et de
d'expliquer ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que on n'est pas des tueurs de sangfroid
tous les états qu'il soi démocrate ou
non ont leur bonnes
raison pour commettre des illégalités
pour se défendre la différence entre un
État autoritaire et un État démocratique
c'est que dans un état démocratique on a
le droit de le
révéler après chacun
juge merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère qu'elle vous a plu n'hésitez
pas à poster un commentaire ou à vous
abonner à la chaîne brut si vous voulez
voir d'autres vidéos de ce style je vous
invite à télécharger l'application brut
vous avez le lien en dessous de la vidéo
à très
vite